[Applause]
please can you help me hey everybody
it's Charlie we got our first look at
Jason Todd aka
future Red Hood on Titan so we got to
break this down there's a big interview
so the showrunner said a whole lot about
how they're gonna be using the character
on the series in the way they talk about
their relationship makes it sound like
they are definitely going to turn Dick
Grayson into Nightwing by the end of
season 1 instead of waiting to like
season 2 or season 3 which I think
everybody is on board for so if you're
new to the channel there's a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
first big thing here you see them
standing together they fight together
during what seems like multiple episodes
now episode 7 is titled Jason Todd so
that's obviously very heavy on his
character but the way they use their
supporting cast like Donna Troy who's
not a main character during season 1 but
will be during season two is that they
pop up in multiple episodes so just
because you're seeing him in this scene
right here doesn't mean that this will
be the only episode that he appears in
now obviously there are two pictures
here I think they're from the same
episode in the same scene just slightly
different angles the whole idea here
being that Dick Grayson left Batman on
bad terms but Batman has already taken
Jason Todd as his next Robin the way
they talked about it this is the first
time the dick race and realizes that
Batman's taken another protege like oh
my god there's another Robin he's the
younger version of me what the hell's
going on this isn't gonna end well part
of the reason why Dick Grayson isn't so
hot on Batman and he left is because he
feels like Batman is really bad raising
children he was turning into Batman and
he felt like that was too brutal like
I'm turning into this crazy monster so
Dick Grayson leaves goes to Detroit but
now he's learned that Batman has taken
another Robin and he's worried that the
same thing is gonna happen to him
correctly so because we've all read
death in the family so we know that it's
not gonna end well for Jason Todd there
is no way that they are not developing a
Red Hood TV show spin-off at some point
it might take them a couple seasons to
get there we'll talk about that in a
second but because the lighting is kind
of dim in this you can't see the version
of the Robin costume that he's wearing
is almost identical to the one that Dick
Grayson is wearing it's the same basic
armor except that Dick Grayson when the
see
picks up is still using the Tim Drake
both its retractable I'm guessing that
by the end of the series he'll split
that we'll get to the Escrima sticks and
it'll be more core Nightwing but the are
shaped throwing stars that he has
actually come out of that chest piece so
the gold are there isn't a symbol those
are the actual throwing stars he just
clicks them in and clicks them out one
at a time as he needs to throw them so
when he wants to throw them at people he
just reaches into his chest like he
doesn't have to pull them out of a
pocket or a utility belt like Batman
uses they're literally sitting there
embedded in his chest piece there's
tension between them the showrunner said
that that's mostly because Jason Todd is
a fresh Robin he's pretty new at the job
and he thinks is the best possible thing
that could have happened to him you
remember that Jason Todd's origin story
is very different from dick Grayson's
they're both orphans but Jason Todd was
actually caught by Batman stealing
medical supplies from Leslie Thompson so
he was more of an heir do well than Dick
Grayson whose parents died at the big
circus accident you see in all the
trailers so amongst superhero orphan
origin stories Jason Todd is just way
more hardcore so obviously he loves how
hardcore Batman is but Dick Grayson
because he's been through all that has
more of a broader understanding of how
it shaped him as a person and at the
moment at least he thinks that that's a
bad thing obviously I think eventually
he'd be able to contextualize it so that
Nightwing when he becomes Nightwing will
eventually be able to work with Batman
again and be on good terms but they just
don't start out in that place so
obviously when they meet for the first
time Jason Todd is probably gonna hate
Dick Grayson because he left why would
you leave the greatest job in the world
fighting with the world's greatest
superhero in Dick Grayson is gonna do
that thing where he tries to be his big
brother like look kid this is gonna end
very badly for you you're too young to
understand that now but someday you will
come back and say you were right
hopefully he won't come back and try to
kill him immediately after becoming Red
Hood so because of this whole arc and
the idea that Batman just leads kids
down this bad path or at least Dick
Grayson thinks that and Jason Todd will
eventually die I think it's pretty safe
to assume that within the next two to
three years we see Red Hood on the TV
show I would be blown away if they do
death in the family before the end of
season one it just
like too big of a story arc to do right
out of the gates and it seems like Jason
Todd is pretty fresh as a Robin right
here so you do have to have that
honeymoon period where he's just jazzed
up about going out and taking down
criminals and Gotham and then you can do
that Joker arc so I'm guessing right now
he's high school age maybe he's like 15
maybe a little bit younger than Beast
Boy or about the same age Raven is still
the youngest kid on the show and I think
she's supposed to be about 13 as of
episode 1 I did a Red Hood video a
little while ago explaining how they
might turn him into Red Hood and what
the timing of that could be but a lot of
that's based on the age in the comics
when Jason Todd became Red Hood and they
might change that a little bit for the
TV show but because Red Hood is such a
popular character of course they would
try to do a Red Hood in the outlaws TV
show but you can't really do that until
you do this big death in the family arc
and you can't do that till like season 2
season 3 so yeah it's gonna be a couple
years but if you're really excited at
the potential for a show like that they
can get there but the whole thing about
season 1 is sort of creating the world
of this series I can't get into spoilers
because I have seen the first couple of
episodes but once I do post my review
video during New York Comic Con I'll
explain a little bit about how they
populated the Titans universe with other
Justice League level
superheroes and how that's different
from the way the arrow verse is handling
those big characters like Batman
Superman Wonder Woman trust me there is
a lot to talk about but they're not
dropping the series till October 12th
but I'll be able to post my early
non-spoilery review the week before that
so you won't have to wait too long
before getting that but because we don't
have footage of him yet this is what the
showrunner quotes about Jason Todd he
says what I really loved about him as a
character is the unbridled sense of self
that he has there's this lack of maybe
quote/unquote self-awareness but for
sure self-consciousness in terms of how
he comports himself and how he moves
through the world
he's completely seemingly unaffected by
darkness
he's talking about Raven and some of the
more occult things that are happening on
the series he kind of embraces it or
walks right through it he's a breath of
fresh air and that's what I love about
him he's got a punk rock no-holds-barred
attitude that's massively unburdened
there's a lot of energy that comes with
that I had to take him down you
shattered his collarbone
he's a drug-dealing pimp I didn't think
I had to prop up some pillows before I
took him out so that's him saying that
he just super jazzed up about everything
they're doing no matter how dark it gets
in Dick Grayson is fighting that
darkness so we'll get into that when we
start talking about the first couple of
episodes post all your reactions in the
comments below I am going to the my hero
academia premiere so I'll post a
non-spoilery review after I see that so
that should be up like Friday afternoon
or something like that I'll be getting a
lot of requests to do videos for that
series so I'll just name a new giveaway
winner when I post new DC that should be
this weekend but there'll be a whole
bunch of stuff coming up with New York
Comic Con what you wait for everything
click here for my new Avengers 4 teaser
breakdown and click here for that brand
new flash trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight